so so i'm talking about you the ability
to build things so did you have the
image of walt did you say i want to do
it oh man i was gonna say i went to the
ventriloquist convention and there was a
guy okay back to edgar bergen had made a
bergen for a disney movie had a frowning
charlie made a real a frowning charlie
that was a pirate just looked like that
right right and uh there was a guy a
dummy maker at the convention that made
a frowning dummy an old man dummy right
and uh nobody in the dealer's room would
touch the thing like what are you going
to do with a frowning dummy he's not
happy he can't tell jokes what are you
going to do with that thing and i kept
walking by it going ah there's something
great
yeah and so i said can i and they had a
deal or show and he was just you know he
didn't want to get on stage and i said
can i borrow that for the show and he
goes sure i went back to the room i
wrote like nine jokes for a grumpy old
man i thought this will work for about
three minutes and i went on stage and
killed with it for about 10 minutes and
so i went back to him and i said could i
buy this from you and again this was
1986. i said can i buy this from you and
it was 2 000 bucks and he goes yeah i
said can you give me a break on the
cost because i don't have a thousand
bucks does 2000 bucks to spend on a
dummy goes nope the price is what it is
i said i think i'll make him famous and
he goes nope price is what it is like
okay so i went back home i made my own
frowning dummy with a mirror uh and a
and a chunk of clay and a knife and i
pretty much you know sculpted my own
face in old man form and uh that was
that
it's a great never sculpted before nope
never sculpted before so i just
that's that's so [ __ ] amazing
yeah and then this this walter is is
version two so uh is he that different
like can i see his face he's not much
different what happened was i got on the
best damn sports show period remember
with tom wilson yeah yeah yeah and i'm
sitting with these giant athletes and
i'm on two or three times and walter was
very tiny right and it looked didn't
look right so i went home and i built a
uh i built a bigger walter and by the
time i got him finished they didn't want
me on the show anymore so i had a bigger
walter and that's what i've used and
that's the bigger walter yeah but his
face is how many of these are there this
one and the and the one uh the original
one and then another one that i made for
the hertz commercial saw that i did
hurts commercial where we had to get wet
and we were in a so i had to make a
waterproof one beck
you got to make a waterproof puppet let
me bring him out i love him does the
character come first and then the jokes
or then you or jokes and then you think
of a character to create that's a really
good question uh nowadays what i've been
doing is i just think up the character
yeah i think up the character and then i
build the character and then the jokes
and then the jokes but the character is
sometimes a joke like it would with
ahmed it was like because
911 you know you said okay i'm gonna do
11 jokes let me come up with ahmed well
i didn't do 911 jokes i did jokes about
the idiots that caused 911 right right
well that's different
completely different yeah
exactly
let me this is amazing
look at that but can you imagine that he
he carved that no i sculpted him
see usually
what's the difference between carving
and sculpting sculpting is with clay and
then you make a mold and then you you
put whatever whatever you want in the
way yeah yeah sure hey
and you were talking about um looking at
the dummy when uh you know he's talking
my favorite thing is when i do like a
television interview and the guy with
the microphone does this oh yeah you
know
yeah he'll move the mic like no no i get
this is good but you know
[Music]